después de un fin de semana de tensión
en la familia real de jordania el
príncipe de hansa parece haber dado
marcha atrás el medio hermano del rey
había sido puesto bajo arresto
domiciliario el fin de semana junto con
otras 16 personas por presuntamente
conspirar para desestabilizar el país
pero ahora el palacio asegura que la
situación ha des escalado y hamza firmó
una declaración en la que jura lealtad
ante el monarca voy a permanecer fiel al
legado de mis ancestros siguiendo sus
pasos leal a su camino y a su mensaje y
a su majestad antes el sábado el
príncipe hamza había publicado un vídeo
en el que acusaba a la dirigencia
jordana de corrupción pero negaba a ser
parte de cualquier complot
los eeuu la mayoría de potencias del
golfo y la liga árabe se apresuraron
para manifestar su apoyo al rey abdulá y
a su gobierno que es visto como un pilar
de estabilidad en la región
valoramos su integridad división y como
dijimos durante el fin de semana de
manera muy clara el rey tiene nuestro
apoyo total el príncipe hans es una voz
crítica del liderazgo del país y en 2004
el rey abdulá le arrebató el título de
príncipe heredero